so this week we've been learning just
little piecemeal
about what was taking place behind the
scenes in the prior administration at
the start of the pandemic one
completely off the wall bullet point
that we got
was that donald trump was looking at
sending
americans who were infected with the
virus to
the guantanamo bay detention center in
cuba i mean just completely out of this
world
bonkers insanity there is now a new
report
uh in slate that summarizes more of what
we are increasingly learning
and it is really wacky wacky stuff uh
the slate article
says the evidence of trump's pandemic
sabotage keeps piling up a new book
shows how he concealed the crisis to
protect his image and
it is unbelievable um the
article uh talks about uh this this
uh book by yasmin abudolab and damian
paleta
from the washington post and it points
out that they present their findings in
the new book nightmare scenario inside
the trump administration's response to
the pandemic that changed history
the book relies in part on interviews
with former trump officials
won't be available until june 29th but
there are excerpts quoted in the post
that describe
several incriminating episodes in at
least two cases trump tried to keep
infected americans from setting
foot in the united states not to prevent
the virus from spreading but to prevent
the infections from being counted as
part of trump's record
in one instance trump's opposition to
letting 14 americans return from a
cruise ship the diamond princess
the authors add backstage details trump
complained to alex azar his secretary
of health and human services that the
return of the infected americans
doubles my numbers overnight that was
when trump was telling us that 15 cases
would soon be zero
the authors report that trump tried to
fire the official who approved the
decision
the book also reveals a second episode
previously unreported
in which trump repeatedly proposed that
americans who had been infected
should be shipped to the u.s military
base at guantanamo bay cuba don't we
have an island we own trump asked
what about guantanamo the word island
was central to trump's idea according to
the authors he was eager to suppress the
numbers on u.s
soil and figured if you keep people off
the mainland they don't count
in both cases the infected citizens
could have been quarantined at
facilities in the continental u.s
that would have impeded the spread of
the virus but trump in his own words
viewed the presence of such people on
the mainland
as a threat to him statistically none of
this should surprise us
trump's biggest concern was testing the
authors right
by producing test kits for the virus and
administering them to more and more
americans doctors and the government
were gradually ascertaining the breath
of the crisis trump chafed at this
progress he said it made him look bad
because he figured if people weren't
tested infections wouldn't be recorded
and it wouldn't be counted against him
the authors report a phone call to azar
testing is killing me i'm going to lose
the election
because of testing what idiot had the
federal
government do testing this is not
new information in the sense that these
things were previously reported
but the degree to which trump's sole and
primary focus
was how he would look and you know the
the unfortunate thing about all this
is that trump doesn't care about anybody
he really doesn't trump doesn't care
about his own followers
trump doesn't care about even people who
support him he cares about them
as long as they're useful to him
politically and when they're not he
throws them in the trash like garbage
but the one aspect of this that could
have gone better would have been
if trump had realized at the beginning
the way to win this politically is by
doing what the doctors say
and doing you know look at how new
zealand dealt with the virus
look at how uh taiwan dealt with the
virus look at
there's other examples it was really
good for the leaders
and had trump at the beginning thought
hey
forget about the fact that he doesn't
care about people he never cared about
people
but if trump had said at the beginning
the best thing politically for me
is to manage this virus by doing a ton
of testing which helps people identify
if they're sick and stay home and not
spread the virus if he had done that it
would have been good for him politically
and as i've said many many times before
if donald trump had just done a passably
okay job on the virus
he would be president right now instead
of joe biden there's no question about
that whatsoever
but instead trump's concern was
sabotaging the spread of the virus
containment aspect in order to do what
he believed but
wrongly so that would look good and in
the end
it didn't help it actually was a
complete and total disaster
just a couple of other things here trump
and his aides belittled and resisted
life-saving public health measures
obviously
the book reports that mark short a
veteran trump aide serving as
pence's chief of staff opposed a plan
to send free masks to every household on
the grounds that it would alarm the
public
senior trump officials ridiculed masks
likening them to a training bra
or underwear on your face short also
opposed the economic shutdown that
slowed the spread of the virus in march
and april
and on the rare occasions when trump
pushed subordinates to move more quickly
he did so for personal advantage
not public health in the fall according
to the book
he tried to oust fda commissioner
stephen hahn
for refusing to strong-arm fda
scientists into approving coveted
vaccines
before election day one anecdote
reported in the book
is more significant than it might seem
in late march of 2020 robert cadillac a
senior hhs official
went to trump's senior advisor and
son-in-law jared kushner
with a plan to mass distribute masks
when kushner learned the masks wouldn't
arrive until june he exploded
we'll all be dead by june he told
cadillac in the post's retelling
this conversation comes across as a tale
of delay and frustration
but it's worse than that it shows how
gravely kushner and others in the white
house privately viewed the crisis
which trump was telling americans
publicly the virus would soon disappear
that is the epitome and a microcosm of
the entire handling of the virus
we learned from the bob woodward
interview that trump did trump knew it
was more serious than he was letting on
he said he didn't want to scare people
jared kushner based on this anecdote
clearly knew
privately how serious it was uh
everything
that they did was based on their worst
instincts their most self-centered
instincts and a complete and total
lack of empathy and concern i mean just
a disgusting
expose no individual incident is
particularly shocking
because what was going on publicly was
bad enough but i believe that we will
continue to learn more about this just
about every week
we're learning more about what was going
on and it's as disgusting as you can
imagine